20 years ago on
this night
I anchored
my first broadcast in 360
and it's been 31 years
since I shot my first story.
And since then I've worked
in more than 70 countries
around the world
seeing things
I could never have imagined and spoken
to extraordinary people, often
in very dangerous
and difficult circumstances.
It has been an incredible honor
to do this job
and to work
with such a talented team
of dedicated journalists
here at CNN tonight
because it is the actual anniversary.
We wanted to take some time
and pull together
some of the most memorable moments
from the last 20 years,
starting with this night.
20 years ago,
Live from the CNN
Broadcast Center in New York,
this is Anderson Cooper.
and a good evening to you.
Thanks for joining us.
I'm Anderson Cooper.
Welcome to our debut hour.
We're following a number of developments
for you tonight.
Tonight from Port
au Prince in Cairo,
a day of dramatic developments.
We are in the city of Manaus,
which is really in
the heart of the Amazon.
We are live tonight from Baghdad,
live in New Orleans.
There is desperation
and there is danger
in the city of New Orleans tonight.
And what you are about to see in
this next hour
is going to shock you
that this is taking place
in the United States of America
in this day and age,
people stuck in their homes right now.
No electricity, no ice,
nothing cool to drink.
They don't know where to go.
They don't know what to do
and they don't
really have any information.
I want to thank Senator
Frist and Senator Reid
for their extraordinary efforts Anderson.
Tonight, I don't know if you've heard
maybe you all have announced it,
but Congress is going to
an unprecedented session
to pass a $10 billion
supplemental bill tonight to keep FEMA
across, up and operating.
Excuse me, Senator.
I'm sorry for interrupting.
I haven't heard that
because for the last four days,
I've been seeing dead bodies
in the streets here in Mississippi.
And to listen to politicians
thanking each other
and complimenting each other.
You know, I got to tell you,
there are a lot of people here
who are very upset
and very angry and very frustrated.
And when they hear politicians slap,
you know, thanking one another,
it just
you know, it
kind of cuts up the wrong way right now.
Because literally,
there was a body on the streets
of this town yesterday
being eaten by rats
because this woman
had been laying in the street
for for 48 hours
and there's not enough facilities
to take her up.
Do you
do you get the anger that is out here?
Good evening.
I'm Anderson Cooper in Marathi, Niger.
Starving in plain sight.
The food crisis in Niger.
That's exactly what is happening here.
A crisis,
a food shortage,
the likes of which
this country has rarely seen
the level of everyday
violence here in the Democratic
Republic of Congo
has been simply unfathomable
over the last several years.
Guns and machetes, of course, are common.
But the most ruthless, ruthless weapon
that has been used here is rape here.
But there are injured
people in the neighborhood
just point
fingers and say,
you are raped woman
and you are infected with AIDS.
She and her children
have been living here in Goma
for the last five months.
Angela would like to be able
to return to her home village,
but that's simply impossible.
The men who raped her
are likely still living in the area.
They of course, have never
been brought to justice.
We're on
a way to see General Laurent Nkunda.
He's a rebel commander
with several thousand troops.
So far, he's
been unwilling to give up his weapons.
He's been accused of a host of war crimes
and human rights violations.
His troops are known to have looted
villages, raped women.
He's been accused
of ordering the summary executions
of dozens of prisoners
the Congolese government issued
an international arrest warrant for him,
but so far, it seems no one's
been able or willing to apprehend him.
When the U.S.
military helicopter
headed toward a forward
operating base
in eastern Afghanistan
along the Pakistan border.
We're actually now
just getting some fire.
Some rockets have been fired
We're coming to you tonight
live from Gaza City, where today
we have seen continued violence.
Also, two media centers being closed
That was a rather large explosion.
We've come to Iraq this week,
along with a platoon of CNN producers
and correspondents
to look at exactly what is happening here
on the military and the political fronts.
Before we go on this journey,
we're giving warnings about what to do
if we're hit by an IED,
by grenades or by small arms fire.
This security situation
where we are has changed somewhat
in the last 30 minutes or so.
We've been advised
to actually turn off our lights,
get down on the floor
and try to barricade
ourselves in the area that we're in.
So that's what
that's why we're doing this program
like this tonight.
It's not going to look very good
over the next hour.
But I hope you bear with us,
because what has happened today in Egypt
and on these streets
has been nothing short of extraordinary.
My cameraman, Neil Holdsworth
and my producer, Marianne Fox
and I were heading toward
Liberation Square
in order to report on both sides
of that protest.
Suddenly, a man jumped out of the crowd
and tried to grab Neil's camera.
That's when all hell broke loose
people started throwing punches,
pushing us around, screaming.
We immediately decided to turn around
and try to get to a safe location.
Several Egyptian men helped us,
but still the crowd followed,
throwing punches.
That man
there had a knife in his hand and
he
kept joining in, trying to punch us.
We only had about a block left to go
when another guy came up
and punched me in the head.
I've been hit now
like ten times
Yep.
Egyptian soldiers
use it for
soldiers who are doing nothing
on the one.
Finally, we reached a safe location, but.
And
we go
with the first live
here's Leah.
All we were trying to do today
was report
on both sides of this conflict.
We're saying that there's two teams now
that are inside the mine.
They've made their way about 4800 feet
towards the trapped workers.
In a minute. Wait a minute.
Charlie. Charlie.
We got to come back come back to us.
The rope is there. All.
Where do I come here?
What's happening?
There's only one.
There's only one. Made it out alive.
You were inside the church?
We were inside the church. And.
And you said there's fierce fighting now.
Yeah.
People are screaming. You're a liar.
You've lied to us.
We come over here, please.
And misinformation, and it's awful.
And you.
You kids were in the church, too? Yeah.
And you heard this?
Yeah. We tried to run away.
We.
I took the kids,
and we ran out of the church
as fast as we can.
I can hear yelling
now over the screaming and yelling,
and the police are in a big draw,
and I don't know how
something like this can happen.
This is CNN breaking news
tonight from Port au Prince.
Haiti, the epicenter of this
horrible earthquake which has struck here
more than 24 hours ago.
Our correspondents have fanned out
throughout the port of Port City of Port
au Prince throughout this day,
bringing you
the latest information
as we have seen it through our eyes
and as the Haitian people
are experiencing it
every minute,
wherever you are watching this broadcast
throughout the world,
I hope you can hug a loved one close
and thank God that you are not in Port
au Prince tonight.
Monley
Alisa was brought to General Hospital
by his uncle
who says he found him
in the rubble alive.
After nearly eight days,
Monley was covered in dust,
weak and limp.
A doctor and a nurse quickly gave him.
And I've got them because as you said,
Lisa, you feel good
He's already looking better
since he's gotten here.
You might have some complications.
Maybe he's
got a very good chance of survival.
And joining us now is Monley.
We're very happy to have him here.
And registered nurse
Gabriella McAdoo,
who is from Stanford
Hospital in California.
But when I first saw him this morning,
I didn't recognize the moment he's here.
He's hydrated now.
And when we first got him,
he was dehydrated.
So we gave him some fluids.
And after eating and drinking, he just
this process is great.
2 hours ago or so, when when
when you guys heard distinctive tapping.
Is it possible
that was just ambient noise?
It very well
could have been the other possibility
is that a person expires
at the tap at one point
and then they're no longer able to.
Mr. True.
This is we're four days into it
without food or water,
and we're talking about possibly
a ten year old girl.
And there's only
every human has their limits.
Their last hope
is to lower several microphones
in different parts of the building.
They've now placed four microphones
in separate locations
on the ground floor in the rubble.
This is a critical moment.
If they hear something
they'll continue working.
If they don't get any response,
they're going to stop the operation.
It's scary.
I can't get more into the repertoire
that deep down in the movies.
This is what a small sound
would be heard.
A faint tap, a child's cry.
But this is Haiti and this is real
And despite their best hopes,
they hear no sound of life.
You can
just see a chunk of
concrete or rock thrown
by one of the looters from the roof.
A young boy is hit in the head.
That's him
there on the ground,
captured on my DV camera.
If he stays there, he might get killed.
But I pick him up
to carry him to the barricade.
Blood is pouring
from his head.
He's clearly stunned
and can't walk
through
not
having
to hand him
over the barricade.
Well, probably no
carried away at this
A massacre that happened in a gay
nightclub
just a block
from where
I'm standing, just down that road
two nights ago.
There were more than a list of names.
There are people who loved
and were loved.
There are people who have families
and friends and dreams.
He was incredibly lucky to have you as.
I was
my luck
started when I gave birth to my son.
She had been wanting a phone for so long,
and we finally got it for her.
And
she just tried to call the police.
She tried to call.
She actually tried to call
Yes.
I got confirmation from
two of the students in her classroom that
she was
just trying to call the authorities
And I guess he just
you look at this
girl shooter
I cannot believe
that Texas officials
from the governor on down
are just now silent.
There's no new information coming out.
It's just not the way you do
these investigations
or how you give information.
They should have given us
a full briefing from the beginning.
You know, that's how they do things.
And then these shootings get a briefing.
And it's not just reporters.
It's the grieving families
who want to know why their children.
I'm not sure they have ever told
the families exactly what happened here.
Keeping Them Honest.
Keeping Them Honest. Keeping Them Honest.
It is hard where.
Give me some evidence.
Tell me one person at one terror
baby that's been born.
Can you tell me
you are telling people
that this cures COVID?
You have no studies to prove it
and you're saying, you know,
some people when I got to one study,
when I where come on.
I thought it was funny.
She's a pretty woman.
You're running for president
of the United States.
I didn't start it.
I didn't start.
Sir, with all due respect.
That's the argument of a five year old.
I didn't start it.
This is pretty much
the strangest assortment I've ever had.
Nobody laugh
presents.
Up next. Oh, thank you.
You can appreciate it. Very nice.
Very funny, huh?
I've been having bunny jokes
around the office
for several weeks now,
so these characters appreciate it.
This brings us to tonight's
edition of things
I'd never thought I'd say.
Mike and I do not exist.
They are not real people.
They are candy,
and as such, do not possess genitals.
Now, also,
just for the record,
Sour Patch Kids are not real kids.
Starbursts don't have real stars in them.
And there isn't an actual ranch
where the Jolly Rancher works.
Last night
on a flight from Paris
to Dublin, Depardieu
reportedly peed on the floor.
Now, all I can say is
they should thank their lucky stars.
It wasn't hard to
follow
And then they giggle
every time I read it.
He hasn't commented on this incident.
Or far.
I know you got it, but
right.
Sure.
Actually never happened to me.
No,
I am truly grateful for the opportunity
that I'm giving each night.
And I strive to get better
every single day.
And I want to thank you all
for watching all these years.
And I'm certainly grateful
for all the men and women
who put this program together
and who dedicate their lives at CNN
to telling the stories that matter.